herzlich willkommen Sibille Krämer
Gabriele kamammelsberger und Jörg Noller
zu diesem kleinen Interview zur
philosophischen
digitalisierungsforschung indem wir uns
über das digitale die Digitalität und
auch seinen Einfluss ihren Einfluss auf
die Wissenschaft unterhalten wollen
vielen Dank dass ihr euch die Zeit
genommen hat habt und ich würde sagen
wir gehen relativ direkt in das
Gespräch und wir starten wie in der
Philosophie mit den Grundbegriffen
Digitalisierung Digitalität die ja
heutzutage auch in großen Teilen des
gesellschaftlichen Diskurses vorhanden
sind anzutreffen sind dabei sind die
Begriffe oft relativ unscharf benutzt
auch teilweise als politische
kampfbegriffe benutzt und soweit ich es
nachvollziehen konnte wurde der Begriff
ja der Digitalität vor allem
insbesondere von Felix Stalder in seinem
Buch Kultur der Digitalität von 2016
prominent gemacht stark in der Pädagogik
ipiert aber auch in anderen Begriffen
anderen Disziplinen
aufgegriffen das digitale gibt's ja aber
schon deutlich länger und staler hat ja
auch eine dezidiert
kulturwissenschaftliche Perspektive
keine dezidiert philosophische und daher
ist die Frage ob was die Philosophie mit
diesem Begriff machen möchte und das
wäre tatsächlich auch meine
Einstiegsfrage an euch wovon sprechen
wir denn eigentlich wenn wir vom
digitalen oder der Digitalität in der
Philosophie sprechen oder sprechen
wollen W mal ganz
[Musik]
anfangen ja Gabriele dann fang doch mal
an dann schließe ich mich gerne an ja
ich glaube wir haben zwei sehr
unterschiedliche digitalitätsbegriffe
also ich halt wirklich nur das
technische als das digitale also das mit
Computer gesteuerte einfach aus
vielleicht Bequemlichkeitsgründen aber
das ist für mich dann einfacher zu
fassen philosophisch und
das digitale ist glaube ich mehr als das
was man so landesüblich mit binarität
verbindet wenn man das aus der Tradition
her sieht wo es auch herkommt der
Begriff von shennon dann ist es einfach
dass
dasit also mit das quantitativ
erfassbare ob man das dann binär
darstellt ist ja noch mal eine zweite
Frage aber man kann es natürlich auch
mit anderen mit den klassischen Zahlen
darstellen aber diese
diese technische hinter ist für mich
sozusagen der
entscheidende ja ich fange ja auch immer
ganz gerne historisch an und da fallen
mir gleich zwei Dinge ein etymologisch
digits die Finger in den von den Fingern
abzählen also für das digitale ist es
zuerstm wichtig dass etwas diskret ist
wie die Finger die aber natürlich nur
funktionieren als Teil der Hand und des
Körpers also der Zusammenhang zwischen
Diskretisierung einerseits und dann
einem
Funktionszusammenhang der mehr ist als
die Summe der Teile andererseits finde
ich sehr wichtig und andererseits also
auch noch mal historisch für mich gibt
es ich nenne das eine embryonale
Digitalität vor dem Computer also es ist
so eine kleine Mission von mir den
Begriff des digitalen auch
computerunabhängig zu denken denn z.B
das ale positionssystem ebenso wie das
Alphabet gehen hervor aus einer
Diskretisierung eines Kontinuums und
wenn wir das digitale so grundsätzlich
und das ist ja auch Philosophie angehen
dass wir davon ausgehen ein Kontinuum
wird in Bausteine zerlegt die dann
codierbar sind ob in Zahlen oder in
welchem Code auch immer und wiederum
kombinierbar und re kombinierbar sind
wenn man also diesen wirklich simplen
Begriff des digitalen zugrunde liegt
gibt es ich besone das noch mal eine
Digitalität z.B in Form der
Alphabetisierung des Sprechens schon vor
dem Computer ich kann dann gerne noch
was das mache ich jetzt aber nicht
sofort zur zeitgenösslichen Digitalität
sagen die damit natürlich überhaupt
nicht erfasst ist denn dazu gehört die
datifizierung aber das mache ich nicht
jetzt im Moment
dafür haben wir nachher noch Zeit
gör ja ich versuch so ein Mittelweg
zwischen Sibille und Gabriele
einzuschlagen ich konzentriere mich auch
eher beim Begriff der Digitalität auf
die neuen Medien anfüungsstrichen
unterscheidet Digitalität aber von
Digitalisierung von technischen Phänomen
und für mich ist Digitalität ganz stark
lebensweltliches Phänomen also die
Nutzung die Integrierung der digitalen
in unsere alltägliche Praxis und dabei
wird für mich auch der Begriff
dertualität se zentral nämlich die
Möglichkeit mit digitalen Medien
herkömmliche Praktiken ja neu zu
realisieren und das verstehe ich eben
unter Virtualisierung also von diesem
lebensweltlichen Fokus her komme ich
wenn ich die den Begriff der Digitalität
betrachte danke schön da sehen wir schon
das ist ein breites Panorama aber ihr
seid ihr kommt ja auch alle diezitiert
aus der
Philosophie was ist denn philosophisch
interessant an dem Thema warum kann man
nicht sagen das ist ein historisches
Thema oder soll die Informatik
bearbeiten oder ähnliche Disziplinen
warum braucht es eine philosophische
Perspektive also ich glaube das
philosophische braucht es deswegen weil
das digitale ist mittlerweile so
allumfassend und so durchtrringend in
die Lebenswelt eingebettet das es
einfach mit zur Wirklichkeit gehört und
in dem Zusam hang sind natürlich
Philosophen und PhilosophInnen
aufgerufen drüber nachzudenken welche
transformativen Kräfte das hat wie das
auf klassische Kategorien wirkt wie das
das Subjekt
objektverhältnis verändert da hat ja jör
seinem Buch auch einiges Interessantes
gesagt also da also diese
allumfassenheit also vor 50 Jahren hätte
man vielleicht noch nicht so intensiv
drüber nachgedacht da war Kybernetik
natürlich das große
Thema aber heute muss man da einfach
drüber
nachdenken ja und man könnte vielleicht
auch wirklich diese Idee die Jörg
aufgebracht hat die lebensweltliche
Veränderung und eben transformative
Kraft wie Gabriele gerade sagte also ich
will das in einem Beispiel klar machen
die Philosophie hat immer schon über der
Kategorien Raum und Zeit nachgedacht
jetzt nur um es am Beispiel der Zeit
wirklich ganz selektiv klar zuumachen
bergon hatte der Philosoph noch zwei
Zeitarten und unterschieden die
gemessene Objektive Zeit die wird
verräumlicht und die subjektiv erlebte
Zeit der Dauer ich glaube jetzt dass die
zeitgenössliche Digitalisierung eine
dritte Zeitform beginnt zu etablieren
ich nenne das ja na nicht ich nenne das
sondern es wird
populär Echtzeit genannt das heißt der
Computer arbeitet mit solcher
Geschwindigkeit dass Menschen keine
Zeitintervalle mehr wahrnehmen können
obwohl natürlich innerhalb des Computers
jede seine Aktionen ein zeitindex hat
also et es wird Zeit konsumiert aber der
Mensch nimmt dies nicht mehr als ein
Vergehen von Zeit wahr und ich glaube
dass dieses
echtzeitphänomen das auch irgendwo die
reflexive dist reflexive Distanz des
langsamen Denkens tendenziell abbaut nur
ein Beispiel wäre wo philosophische
Reflektion wie ich meine einsetzen
könnte ja also auch ich glaube dass wir
eine neue zeitliche Form auch eine neue
räumliche Form vorfinden durch die
Digitalität und ich habe das mit dem
Begriff der M
interobjektivität auch mal versucht
Anschluss von yukui zu bestimmen also es
wird auch phänomenologisch sehr
interessant was sich am phänomenalen
alltäglichen Bereich ändert glaube wir
treten in neue Relationen die Relationen
haben auch eine Ausdehnung aber eben
nicht mehr räumlich physisch zumal wir
eben auch mit Geräten in eine ganz neue
mit maschineen in ganz neues Verhältnis
treten was dann auch ein Raum eröffnet
ein virtuellen Raum ein digitalen Raum
kein physischen Raum mehr der eben auch
erweitert werden kann wenn dieser Medien
Bezug sinnvoll ist der aber auch
kollabieren kann kan wie im Falle von
filterblasen wenn KI Räume erzeugt die
sich nur um uns selbst drehen also ich
glaube man kann mit dem Raumbegriff
ziemlich viel
anfangen auf die
Digitalität allerdings noch mal auch ein
Anspruch h das das virtuelle bleibt
natürlich Material gebunden also z.B ist
der
Ressourcenverbrauch in der
zeitgenössischen künstlichen Intelligenz
aber auch in anderen
ein absolut wichtiger Faktor also ist es
nicht manchmal so dass es da auch einen
gewissen Mythos der entkörperung gibt
der uns vergessen lässt die materielle
Basis die wir alle an der Nabelschnur
des Stroms hängen als Bedingung der
Möglichkeit überhaupt noch irgendetwas
öffentlich sagen und schreiben zu können
und das ist wiederum ich komme aus einer
eher kulturtechnischen Perspektive für
mich ein ganz wichtiges Problem weil ich
auch wirklich glaube dass der
Ressourcenverbrauch der Computernutzung
ein Faktor ist der noch viel zu selten
bedacht wird ja das nur als kleiner
Einwand oder kleiner
kommentarergänzung ich ich stimme den
ganz zu würde aber sagen dass die
virtuelle Realität emergiert auf der
materiellen Basis sowie auch ein
Geldschein ein virtuellen Wert hat der
real ist
obwohl er oder trotzdem er eine
materielle Basis hatte schließt sich gar
nicht aus es sind die Kontexte die
Konfiguration die dann auf der
materiellen Basis Virtualität
ermöglichen aber das hängt natürlich
nicht nur in der Luft da ich stimme ich
Dir ganz zu also vielleicht kann ich da
jetzt die vermittelnde Position
einnehmen ich glaube äh ich bin ja an
sich nicht so jemand die auf Heider
zitiert aber ich glaube hier dieser
Begriff des entbergens ähm der den kann
man also das technischer als eine Weise
des entbergens kann man hier super gut
verstehen weil nämlich mit Energie die
wird symbolisch entborgen also um um das
so weiter zu stricken und das ist
irgendwie ein neues Phänomen also also
jetzt schon älter weil wir das mit dem
Computer eben zum ersten Mal
durchführen und da kommen dann eben
diese diese Kategorien wie Virtualität
oder oder hier emergiert etwas im Spiel
aber tatsächlich sind das technische
Weisen des entbergens deswegen ist das
digitale für mich eben auch diese
technische Komponente ähm und das AT ja
heideger damals an den
Energietechnologien beschrieben die sich
ja auch ganz schwer fassen lassen aber
im Grunde wird Energie in Symbol
umgewandelt und diese diese symbolische
Ausbeutung der Energie das ist das was
man wie man den Computer auch Material
beschreiben kann denke ich ganz
gut und das kostet wahnsinnig viel Strom
und das wird wahrscheinlich noch
gigantisch zunehmen an an an
ressourcenverbräuchen spart andererseits
auch etwas ein aber ähm da sind sich
alle noch uneinig wie wie nachhaltig
oder unnachhaltig das verwendet werden
kann
ja genau also Strom ist eine Bedingung
der Möglichkeit wir dürfen auch sowas
wie Satellitentechnik und ähnliches
nicht vergessen die ja auch äh notwendig
sind für dieses Gesamtgefüge
ähm aber jetzt haben wir auch schon hier
so ein Panorama gehört dass sich
sozusagen ähm durch die diese
gesamttechnologie es ist ja nicht nur
eine einzelne Technik sondern wir reden
vom Computer als Universalmaschine als
universelle
repräsentationseinheit von ganz
unterschiedlichen Dingen die in einem
großen System auch zusammengeschlossen
werden von emergenten Effekten aber wir
können vielleicht sagen dass sowohl
ähm sich unsere Lebenswelt verändert
aber auch unser Zugang zu der Lebenswelt
vielleicht sogar wir selbst und hier
wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage
inwiefern schafft denn digital
Technologie einen neuen Zugriff auf die
Welt wie wird die Welt vielleicht sogar
geformt oder verformt wenn wir jetzt an
Mathematisierung formalisierbarkeit von
weltlichen Phänomenen denken ähm aber
eben auch solche Effekte wie Augmented
Reality oder Virtual Reality die ja
wirklich ähm man sagen kann man lebt
nicht mehr in derselben Welt wie
vorher
ähm also ich glaube die die
Grundbedingung dafür ist und deswegen
zitiere ich das auch immer ganz oft Mark
weiser was er beschrieben hat mit
ubiquittis Computing was dann später z.B
auch von Erich HL so als
environmentalität des digitalen
aufgenommen wird ich glaube das ist die
Bedingung äh um dann über diese
zugriffarten und die Mathematisierung
und diese Sachen zu sprechen einfach
weil ähm da da wird das das digitale
tatsächlich auch physisch total und für
mich ist das digitale mehr und mehr und
das hat mit der Entwicklung der
Smartphones zu tun also wir müssen uns
vorstellen es gibt 4 Milliarden
Smartphon Nutzer auf dieser Welt die
über vielleicht 10 12 Plattformen
koordiniert werden also diese
Standardplattform die wir alle kennen
also hier kommt ein wahnsinniger
panoptikumseffekt natürlich rein das ist
das eine aber das andere ist eben auch
dass diese Smartphones das machen sich
die meisten nicht klar nur noch mess
Stationen sind da sind in heutigen
Smartphones sind 20 Sensoren verbaut in
der Regel das sind Mini kleinste
Millimeter große Sensoren auch die
Chiptechnologie in Smartphones ist
wesentlich äh avancierter als in unserem
Computern z.B ähm das sind unfassbare
technische Geräte dieses Smartphones die
alles in der Umgebung inklusive des
Sprechers und sich selbst ähm
digitalisieren also da da B V v
datafixierung gesprochen also alles
umsetzen in Daten in Smartphones sind
mittlerweile auch sogenannte npus also
neuronale also Chips für neuronale
netzwerkverarbeitung um eben auch KI äh
anzuwenden um auch sofort gleich die
ersten Analysen in den Smartphon selbst
in der Hardware selbst zu machen und ähm
und damit auch nicht nur die alles in
Daten aufzulösen die ganze Welt sondern
sie eben auch zugleich zu interpretieren
zum bestimmten Stück weit natürlich
und ähm das heißt vor diesem Hintergrund
ist für mich also diese
environmentalität diese unfassbare
Verbreitung des digitalen diese
Individualisierung durch das Smartphone
also dass der Link zur zur zur
virtuellen Welt individualisiert worden
ist hat mit den PCs also Personal
Computern angefangen ist heute mit den
Smartphones wirklich eins zu eins auf
Menschen gemappt und dass das ganze über
äh diese Daten und Datenauswertung läuft
das das was mir mit telefonieren machen
oder das was das klassisch mediale ist
spielt kaum noch eine Rolle das ist so
eine Oberfläche die braucht man für
Menschen aber es ist eine Frage wie
lange man das nicht braucht ähm und das
ähm ist für mich so der größte impact
hier auf die des digitalen und dessen
Zugriff auf die
Welt meine für mich ist natürlich auch
immer interessant Gabriele dass das du
sagtest eben wir brauchen es nur noch
auf der Oberfläche aber gerade die die
Techniken arbeiten ja auf der Oberfläche
ich will es mal in einem Beispiel das
mich sehr beschäftigt klar macht also
wenn wir sprechen wissen wir natürlich
nicht durch in welchem Häufigkeit wir
Buchstaben wenn wir das verschriften
würden wir Buchstaben benutzen also die
buchstabenstruktur unserer
verschriftetes verschrifteten Sprechens
ist uns völlig unbekannt wir brauchen
das nicht um eine Sprache zu verstehen
aber es gibt diese mathematisch
unterlegte Struktur genauso wie sich die
Planeten bewegen auf bestimmten Bahnen
die mathematisch berechenbar sind selber
aber natürlich dabei nicht rechnen so
kommt es mir manchmal vor gebrauchen wir
natürlich z.B unsere Sprache intuitiv
ohne dass auch nur irgendwelche
rechchenprozesse dabei ablaufen und
jetzt plötzlich sind wir mit einer
Situation konfrontiert in der die
Maschine genau dieses ich nenne das mal
kulturell
unbewusste in unseren symbolischen
Praktiken diese latenten uns aber
verborgenen gleich wohl
quantifizierbaren mathematisierbaren
Strukturen offenlegen kann und aufgrund
denken wir nur an GPT und aufgrund
dieser statistischen Regelmäßigkeiten zu
erstaunlichen Formen auf der Oberfläche
nach menschlichem sprach Gebrauch
aussehenden Äußerung kommt und das finde
ich ist ein völlig neue Rolle die das
mathematische und wenn man so will auch
das quantifizierbare spielt die
natürlich seit Galilee in der das Buch
der Natur in geometrischen Lettern
geschrieben war irgendwie ein oni ist
jetzt aber noch mal eben nicht das Buch
der Natur sondern die Bücher der
Menschen in ihren mathematischen Lettern
um mal die metaphor aufzu greifen
untersuchen kann und das ist für mich
etwas ganz Neues es ist aufregend es ist
riskant und wir wissen noch überhaupt
nicht was da vor allen Dingen im
Hochschulwesen und so weiter auf uns
zukommt aber das scheint mir ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt die Rolle der Mathematik
hat sich noch einmal qualitativ
verändert wenn nach dem Zugriff auf die
Welt gefragt ja das stimme ich auch
vollkommen zu nur das faszinierende ist
auch dass wir davon überhaupt nichts
mehr mitkriegen ja wir kriegen immer
weniger davon mit äh weil die
Oberflächen werden immer geringer die
Daten im Hintergrund ich nenne das gerne
so ikonoklastische Daten also die werden
immer
ikonoklastische also dieses ursprünglich
mediale wofür der Computer gedacht war
auch das geht mehr und mehr verloren
auch die Internet ist vor allem
Maschinen Maschinen Kommunikation ist
nur das ein Bruchteil ist Mensch
Maschinen oder menschmensch
Kommunikation und dieser Verlust des
medialen der auch natürlich unter weil
es alles unterhalb unserer Wahrnehmung
Schwelle läuft sowohl von der
Geschwindigkeit
als auch eben von dem
von der von der Darstellungsweise das
ist das was mir am meisten Sorge macht
und das ist eben genau wie das cbille
gerade beschrieben hat dieses
statistisch
mathematische das eben auch mit channen
schon reinkommt und interessanterweise
greift er da ja auf die auf Markov
zurück und Markov hat seine
Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung an der
russischen
literatural human nennen
entwickelt und in dem Sinn ist der
Computer also das digitale ist
eigentlich das genuin Digital Humanities
auch wenn wir heute in der Philosophie
so viel Schwierigkeiten damit haben aber
dass man da kaum noch Zugang hat das
finde ich das ähm ähm das und immer
abhängiger wird weil diese Massendaten
können ja auch nur noch von Algorithmen
und machine learning Algorithmen
interpretiert werden also die könnten
wir auch gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen
das heißt die die die Autonomie wird
hier mehr und mehr eben auch an das
maschinelle
ähm
übertragen und die Frage ist dann wie
wir da überhaupt noch Zugänge kriegen
und wie die Zugänge gestaltet werden und
das kann man ja auch in der in den
letzten Jahren deutlich sehen es wird
immer affektiver und emotionaler
ähm also die Interfaces werden
natürlicher Sprache wie Alexa aber auch
die Emotion analysis oder Sentiment
analysis nimmt wahnsinnig zu
ähm und dieses affektive wird mehr und
mehr zum Zugang ähm zum digitalen
scheint das so der Fall zu sein also das
ist eine Tendenz die ich so beobachte
und die Frage das hat glaube ich mit dem
was Bille auch gesagt hat zu tun um
überhaupt in dieser wahnsinnigen
Mathematisierung noch einen Zugang zu
kriegen braucht es auch neue Formen
dieses dieser Zugänglichkeit und die
bilden sich gerade heraus und da spielt
das KI glaube ich eine große Rolle aber
so genau lässt sich noch nicht
feststellen wie das dann enden
wird ich finde deswegen die
Digitalisierung so interessant aus
philosophischer Perspektive weil sich
herkömmliche philosophische Fragen
erkenntnistheoretisch ontologisch
ethisch im Medium der Digitalität neu
stellen oder neu revitalisiert werden
z.B die Philosophie des Geistes durch
künstliche Intelligenz die Ontologie
durch digitale virtuelle Objekte die
Ethik durch Menschmaschine Interaktion
also hier kommt bekommen neues Paradigma
äh sodass wir die ganze Tradition neu
könen und ich würde von einem digital
turn in der Philosophie sprechen den wir
jetzt erleben dass wir am Beispiel am
Paradigma der Digitalisierung der
Digitalität noch mal ganz neu durch die
ganzen Disziplinen gehen und die Grenzen
vielleicht auch ins Wanken
geraden ja ich finde natürlich Gabriele
V deine Idee dass der Affekt
kompensiert dass mit Menschen mit
Massendaten nicht mehr umgehen können
sie weder kontrollieren beobachten noch
da interpretieren können den finde ich
ungeheuer
interessant und man könnte das natürlich
wenn man jetzt
noch radikaler denkt sagt ist nicht in
gewisser Weise das was wir
interpretieren nennen immer schon
Ausfluss eines Nichtwissens das heißt
wir lernen zu interpretieren weil wir
keinen Zugang haben zu diesen
verschlossenen Welten der mentalen
Innenwelt des anderen dessen was ein
Autor dachte als er einen Text
geschrieben hat und so weiter und so
fort und sind wir heute nicht eventuell
damit konfrontiert dass die Maschine im
Umgang mit Texten indem sie z.B in der
Lage ist die Bedeutung von Worten aus
den Nachbarschaften oder den
Entfernungen die Worte zueinander in
einem datenkorpus haben dass die
Maschine auch auf dieser Grundlage
eine ein Vorstellung nicht Vorstellung
aber eine
bedeutungs
erreicht die für Menschen überraschend
ist die aber nichts mit Interpretation
zu tun hat sondern tatsächlich mit der
Berechnung des Gebrauch wie witkgenstein
schon sagte der die Bedeutung eines
Wortes ist sein Gebrauch das ist jetzt
verereinfacht witkenstein bitte nicht
jetzt zuwörtlich nehmen aber wenn wir
von dieser Idee ausgehen Bedeutung ist
der Gebrauch eines Symbols dann ist die
Maschine in vieler Hinsicht heute in der
Lage diesen Gebrauch in Bezug auf
riesige datenkorporat die natürlich
Menschen niemals erarbeiten könnten zu
ermitteln und damit auch ein Level des
bedeutungsverstehens zu erreichen obwohl
sie nicht interpretiert und das ist für
mich auch wäre auch ein Beispiel das
auch in Bezug auf oder als Anknüpfen an
J also ein typisches Beispiel für einen
Begriff nämlich Interpretation der jetzt
finde ich unter digitalen Bedingungen
eine ganz neue Dimension bekommen weil
wir akzeptieren müssen dass es einen
operativen bedeutungsbegriff gibt mm und
eben nicht nur den Sinn durch
Interpretation zu erschließen wie es
gemeinin der Fall ist in der textmenut
mm ne also Gebrauch ist da glaube ich
der richtige Zugang weil
also marieelouise Anger hat ja das mit
dem affektiven sehr auch sehr tief
untersucht jetzt ja aus Medien
philosophisch medienwissenschaftlicher
Perspektive die hat das immer stark
gemacht und ich glaube man sieht jetzt
wirklich äh an vielen Beispielen wie das
mehr und mehr kommt und die spannende
Frage wä jetzt hier um das zu verknüpfen
also was du vorher gesagt hast wir
benutzen Sprache äh und wir sind uns
über die der Statistik der Buchstaben
natürlich nicht bewusst aber in dem
Moment wo wir sprechen produzieren wir
Muster und die die und die die
Datenauswertung ist ja eine
musterauswertung also das was
KI und der Computer sehr gut können sind
diese musterauswertungen in den großen
Datenmengen und und diese großen und das
ist ein anderer Gebrauch von Sprache ja
und da liegt jetzt viel Potenzial drin
also z.B Kameras die aufnehmen wie wir
gehen und anhand dessen wie man geht
Muster äh rekonstruiert die auf
Krankheiten rückschließen lassen ja also
bewegungsk Krankheiten wie Parkinson
oder so das kann man sehr früh erkennen
mittlerweile weil das bestimmte
Bewegungsmuster verändert und diese
Bewegungsmuster die lassen sich ähm das
ist ein anderer Gebrauch derselben wie
sagt man Grundlage des Lebens aber eben
anderer Gebrauch eben dieses
mathematisch statistische genauau jetzt
ist aber die spannende Frage
also ich meine es wird ja auch viel mit
Gesichts Interpretation dieser Mimik die
da auf auf Eckman und so weiter zurück
geht es alles sehr vereinfacht noch aber
ähm wie viel lässt sich jetzt in diesem
Gebrauch überführen und ähm und und wie
ist wie ist da der beste Zugang zu weil
es ist eben nicht mehr semantisch
sondern es ist tatsächlich dieses Muster
mm
generiert müssten wir dann aber nicht um
sozusagen nicht in in in so einen Daten
äh Positivismus zu verfallen auch über
einen neuen Muster oder Strukturbegriff
nachdenken denn offensichtlich sind ja
diese Muster und Strukturen die
Maschinen erkennen andere als die die
Menschen erkennen jetzt auch wenn wir an
diagrammatik oder visual Analytics oder
ähnliches denken also sowohl auf
visueller Ebene als auch wenn wir jetzt
Zahlenmaterial anschauen da scheinen ja
Maschinen andere Formen von Mustern zu
erkennen als wir
ähm der musterbegriff ist in der
digitalisierungsforschung ja auch im
Gebrauch mit ein sei ähm brauchen wir
hier so eine Art Begriff der
artifiziellen Muster oder
Strukturen ja also W wenn sie will de
Buch schreiben würde würde es
dieagrammatik der der Muster heißen oder
so also ich glaub
interpretationsform ja na ja äh mus da
eigentlich könnten wir wir könnten
Spuren sagen und dann ist schon eher
klar das Spurenlesen ist eine uralt auch
hermenutische Technik auch der
humananities kasoistische Forschung
Sigmund Freud und kunstfälschung und so
weiter Sherlock Holmes Arbeit am in der
Wende zum 19 Jahrhundert aber ich glaube
das interessante am datentechnischen
musterbegriff ist das Muster in Punkt
Punkt berechenbare
punktkonstellationen aufzulösen sind
also was ein Datum ist muss letztlich
nicht nur in einem Zahlenwert
ausdrückbar sein sondern als eine
punktestruktur wiederzugeben sein und in
dem Sinne hat natürlich dasselbe wie
schon mit der Sprache auch das must da
eine Ebene in der die Maschine uns weit
übertrifft der Computer ist eine
forensische Maschine wie ich immer so
sagte Teleskop und Mikroskop in das
Universum und damit liefert er uns
Ergebnisse die Menschenaugen äh immer
auf immer verschlossen sind also
insofern ist es klar natürlich hat der
musterbegriff eine Seite die sich zum
Menschen neigt das ist die
Spurensuche die aber eben sehr begrenzt
ist und es ist die
quantifizierende Verwandlung von Muster
in datenpopulationen die dann wieder
berechenbar sind und da ist einfach der
Computer zu einem unschlagbar
leistungsgrft
Tool geworden Kirschbaum hat er glaube
ich diesen Begriff wenn auch etwas
anders der
forensischen Maschine geprägt und ich
finde den sehr aufschussreich also das
ist wichtiger als überbrechenbarkeit zu
reden diese Aufdeckung die dechifrierung
von
musterkonstellationen
ja vi aber mir ich ich habe mir eben
etwas notiert Gela das ist aber war aber
etwas was du ganz am Anfang sagtest dass
ich interessant fand also sagtest das
mediale wird irgendwie über zunehmend
überflüssig gemacht also die die
Maschinen korrespondieren mit Maschinen
oder Protokollen und sozusagen es ist
gar nicht mehr der Interaktionspartner
Mensch es ist natürlich daran zu
erinnern dass funktionierende medien die
nicht verrauscht sind denen kein Defekt
sich zeigt immer schon dazu tendieren
sich unsichtbar zu machen also unterhalb
der Schwelle der Wahrnehmung zu bleiben
ich habe das ja in dieser
medienphilosophie des Boten der
eigentlich nur in anführungstrichen das
Sprachrohr einer fremden Auflage ist die
er weiterzugeben hat klar gemacht also
ich glaube diese Tendenz haben Medien
immer schon in ihrem erfolgreichen
Gebrauch scheinen sie zu verschwinden s
dass es eine gewisse immersive
Tendenz des medialen auch immer schon
gibt auch bereits mit dem Roman mit dem
Film der uns in seinen Band zieht und
nicht natürlich mit den immersiven
virtuellen Realitäten in denen das noch
mal radikalisiert wird aber mir ist
diese Idee dass das Verschwinden des
Mediums seinem Gebrauch in gewisser
Weise
funktionslogisch eingeschrieben ist die
ist wichtig die wird jetzt nur eben
radikalisiert ja aber das was du
beschreibst ist ähm also man taucht in
den Film ein dieses imersionspotenzial
hat man im Digital natürlich ganz massiv
und das wird ja immer mehr gefördert und
da kommt das auch affektive wieder rein
weil das braucht man natürlich um diese
imersion dieses imersionserlebnis zu
haben nichtdestotrotz bleibt der Film
immer sichtbar auf der Oberfläche
äh das digitale verschwindet zunehm das
muss nicht mehr sichtbar bleiben das
heißt das was wir ja zu Gesicht bekommen
oder zu hören bekommen ist ja nur ein
winziger Bruchteil des digitalen und äh
dieses Verhältnis wird immer ähm immer
ungleichgewichtiger also wir wir wir
kriegen vom digitalen von diesen
wahnsinnigen Mengen die ja immer mehr
zunehmen
also irgendwie wir sind ja in zarbeit
Daten Universum
glaub 32 zabites oder so gibt es das ist
das sind unfassbar viele wenn man das in
Büchern umrechnet glaub da müsste jeder
von uns eine Million Bücher haben auf
der Welt bei irgendwie 8 Milliarden
Menschen um an dieses diese Datenmenge
ranzukommen das heißt es wird immer ähm
also es im Unterschied zum Film zum Buch
kann die Oberfläche verschwinden und sie
verschwindet mehr und mehr das ist das
was mich bisschen
beunruhigt weil die die Machine Learning
Algorithmen brauchen das nicht die
die Maschinen die gesteuert sind diese
smarten Objekte die brauchen das alles
nicht
und wenn die je autonomer die dann auch
werden durch eben KI desto weniger muss
man das überhaupt noch rückmelden an den
Menschen und deswegen ist die
Automatisierung das ist auch noch ein
Punkt also Mathematisierung aber eben
auch Automatisierung der ganz wichtige
Rolle bei dem digitalen spielt und es
muss sich nur noch ab und an melden bei
uns und das wird immer
weniger und das läuft so alles so im
Hintergrund mit und muss nicht mehr
sichtbar sein und das ist das was ich
meine das ist der Unterschied zum den
klassischen Kulturtechniken die haben
eben nicht diese Unterfläche wie das
Freder n beschrieben hatte des
Prozessierens also es wird ja alles in
Prozessierung aufgelöst und dann muss es
wieder ert werden um dargestellt zu
werden und diese darstellungsfunktion
die den anderen Medien inherent war die
ist jetzt auch fluider geworden und die
muss man nicht mehr haben sorry hier
waren die Müllabfuhr gerade war ziemlich
laut h
gehört glaube man hat es nicht gehört
Jörg du hattest Dich gerade noch
freigeschaltet
genau ja ich glaube wichtiger Punkt ist
auch noch Autonomie im Mediengebrauch
also wir haben hier eine große Gefahr
dass wir von den digitalen Medien
abhängig werden weil sie so viel im
Untergrund machen andererseits haben wir
eine Möglichkeit unsere Autonomie zu
vergrößern weil wir e viel mehr
Möglichkeiten haben also siebille hat
auch mal von der digitalen Aufklärung
gesprochen und die würde ich auch hier
gerade ansetzen in unserem
zweischneidigen näengebrauch einerseits
die Erweiterung der Möglichkeiten des
möglichkeitenraums andererseits die
Bevormundung auch durch algorith also
hier kann man auch noch aus der
Perspektive der Aufklärung viele
interessante Dinge
hervorarbeiten wir müssen natürlich auch
sehen dass äh also das Programm einer
philosophischen Aufklärung unter
digitalen Zeiten halte ich und mit mir
glaube ich hunderte auch anderer die
dazu auch schon was geschrieben haben
für immens wichtig mir ist noch nicht
ganz klar was das alles umfassen würde
aber eines ist klar unser Bewusstsein um
das Nichtwissen und zwar um ein
Nichtwissen das auch nicht aufdeckbar
ist die
175 Millionen Parameter die large
language Models ausbilden auf denen z.B
die GPT Familie und andere auch Bild äh
synthetische Bildmedien basieren äh die
sind in in keiner Weise mehr von nichts
und niemandem mehr in ihrer inneren
Struktur aufdeckbar also der Blackbox
Charakter der Maschine nimmt noch einmal
eine ganz neue Qualität an aber man kann
sich jetzt nicht hinstellen und einfach
vor diesem Risiko waren weil wir müssen
lernen damit zu leben also es geht um
eine Blackbox die wir integrieren müssen
und nicht aufdecken können das wäre die
These wir müssen anerkennen die Grenzen
unserer Erkenntnis werden je
leistungsstärker die Maschine werden
umso weniger können Menschen ihre
Maschinen verstehen wenn jetzt Maschine
als schiffre natürlich für
algorithmenprotokol und alles was daran
hängt und das finde ich einen
interessanten Zusammenhang andererseits
aber auch noch mal zu diesem Stichwort
Aufklärung mich betrückt es immer und
das gilt natürlich schon für den ganzen
Begriff der künstlichen Intelligenz dass
äh im Grunde genommen nicht anerkannt
wird dass das was Maschinen machen Sie
auf eine grundständig andere Weise tun
als Menschen es machen und das gilt
nicht nur für den Kaffeeautomaten
sondern das gilt natürlich erst recht
für die sogenannte künstliche
Intelligenz wir müssen ich meine jetzt
nicht kurzweit sondern wir müssen die
Singularität dessen wie Maschinen
arbeiten das das eine Ontologie ist die
sich in gewisser Weise vom Menschen und
seiner funktionieren und arbeiten und
Erleben völlig unterscheidet das sollten
wir anerkennen aber dann auch nicht
Maschine und Mensch in einen
ersetzungswettbewerb schicken sondern
sehen dass wir ich präge dafür einfach
eine koperform
zwischen Mensch und Maschine oder Mensch
und Technik haben und in dem Sinne
gehört allerdings als eine Dimension
dieser
kerformanz das was ich epistemische
Intransparenz nenne also dass wir
anerkennen müssen dass in diesem
Verhältnis Dimensionen dunkel bleiben
die in keiner Weise aufzudecken sind und
wie kann man dann ein aufgeklärtes
emanzipiertes Verhältnis von Mensch und
Maschine denken wenn die Maschine die
Blackbox wenn die Maschine immer toller
wird und sie immer mehr äh verdeckt wie
ihr Inneres funktionieren ist das finde
ich irgendwie eine herausfordernde Frage
auf die ich noch keine Antwort habe aber
also stimme ich zu aber wir wir sind d
mit den Resultaten der Maschine als
Blackbox konfrontiert also wo ich immer
noch sehr auch an kann an diesem
aufklärerischen Potenzial hänge ist dass
wir durchaus noch im Moment noch solange
die die KI nicht ihre eigenen
Algorithmen schreibt aber dass wir immer
noch nachvollziehen können wie die
Methoden sind die da angewandt werden
also ich habe das ja auch versucht also
diese äh also für mich heißt Kritik des
digitalen eine Kritik der Methoden also
wenn man z.B sagt wie am Anfang der KI
Entwicklung künstliche Intelligenz ist
Problemlösen Problemlösen ist ähm such
suche problemse Problemsuche ist
irgendwann Eingrenzung des Suchraum
und Eingrenzung des suchraumes wird dann
gleichgesetzt mit KI und das ist dann
der berühmte general problem solver mit
der means and analysis Methode die bis
heute Verwendung findet und diese also
die Kritik dieser dieser Methoden und
Verfahrensweisen die die liegt mir im
Herzen und solange wir das noch machen
können können wir zumindest die Art wie
diese Intransparenz generiert wird
verstehen
aber wenn das auch nicht mehr in unserer
Hand liegt was ja auch die Zukunft ist
also die Programmierung wird mehr und
mehr an die KI abgegeben dann äh kann
sich das natürlich auch noch ins
intransparente verlegen und dann wird's
natürlich tatsächlich schwierig das noch
zu beurteilen aber klar Massendaten da
können wir natürlich es war ja auch bei
der Simulation schon also ich meine das
sind so viel Daten die da simuliert
werden da kann man gewisse Verfahren
anwenden um abzuschätzen ob das noch
überhaupt in die richtige Richtung geht
aber man muss dem Ganzen dann schon
schon auch irgendwie Vertrauen ne wir
gerade Jörg verlor verloren im Tunnel
wahrscheinlich genau ich hoffe er kommt
gleich
wieder da würde ich trotzdem gerne noch
mal anknüpfen weil auch Jonathan das
natürlich eine der grundlegenden Fragen
von Philosophien digital ist gibt es
sowas wie eine Kritik der digitalen
Vernunft oder Kritik der Digitalität und
wenn ich jetzt mal etwas ketzerisches
sagen würde frage ich mich obwohl
natürlich kann da die steilvorl uns
gegeben hat sind wir überhaupt noch in
einem Zeitalter in dem die Aufgabe der
Philosophie wirklich die Kritik von
etwas sein kann oder geht es nicht viel
elementarer darum dass wir als
Philosophen und das hast du ja genau
Gabriele auch gemacht mit deinen
Ausführung zur Methode eben aufklären
wie also beschreiben beschreiben und zum
Verständnis also mythten dadurch abbauen
dass wir schlicht weg versuchen die
technologisch algorithmischen Prozesse
so gut es eben geht aus der BTE einer
Philosophin tatsächlich zu beschreiben
und in dem Sinne höchstmöglich
transparent zu machen und ich glaube und
Ringe auch damit hab schon wieder darauf
keine Antwort dass wir irgendwie uns
lösen müssen von
dieser von dieser Übermacht der Idee von
Kritik als der
urprünglichen Aufgabe des
philosophischen
wir müssen zum Verstehen der Welt
beitragen ja aber das ist für mich
Kritik also ich verstanden er wollte
verstehen wie diese Naturwissenschaft
jetzt funktioniert die vom gegebenen
ausgeht also auch von Daten im Übrigen
deswegen finde ich k hier sehr sehr
passend an vielen Ecken und Enden und
wie dieses gegebene in Daten aufgelöste
wie man da eben überhaupt noch Sinn
generieren kann und die Kritik der
reinen Vernunft kann man ja auch als
eine angewandte Mathematik Philosopie vi
lesen in diesem Zusammenhang und die
Prozesse zu klären die kann natürlich
introspektiv gemacht hat die jetzt wir
nicht mehr so introspektiv in diesem
Sinne machen aber die Algorithmen sind
ja auch externalisierte Formen dieser
Introspektion kann man ja auch so
argumentieren um zu verstehen wie das
funktioniert und ich glaube bei der KI
kann man das so schön nachvollziehen
ich habe mir ja viel mit diesen KI
Algorithmen auseinandergesetzt und das
ist das sind so simple Methoden die da
aneinander gereiht werden und die erst
durch diese Aneinanderreihung der simple
Methoden so mächtig werden und ähm durch
diese verschiedenen Strategien die da an
äh kombiniert werden sind ja alles
baukassensysteme wenn wir heute von dem
machine learning Algorithmus sprechen
der existiert nicht es gibt viele
verschiedene das sind baukassensysteme
die zusammengebastelt werden und dann zu
gucken welche Resultate bringen Sie am
Ende das ist auch in der
Naturwissenschaften so der Fall desw
sind das ganz schwere method sind
empirische Methoden im Moment weil jeder
baut in seinem Labor den passenden
Baukasten zusammen aber das ist
überhaupt nicht mehr vergleichbar und
reproduzierbar im klassischen Sinne auch
der Naturwissenschaft n nicht mal von
der Methode her das macht es super
spannend im Moment das meine ich mit
Kritik also diese diese Strategien also
Intelligenz als Problemlösen was ja
schon auf die Kart zurückgeht
Problemlösen als Problemsuche
Lösungssuche so so muss man sagen und
und diese Strategien offen zu legen und
ähm der zweite Punkt das hatte ich ja
auch dem Buch da klar gemacht ist eine
eine Kritik der
Selbstverständlichkeiten also das was
uns so selbstverständlich erscheint
mittlerweile auf der eher phänomenalen
Ebene das müssten wir auch besser
kritisieren das ist ja ein bisschen das
Programm was ähm was was ähm na
Blumenberg für die Technik generell im
Anschluss an hussal angekündigt hatte
also das Selbstverständliche ist ja
eigentlich das was man nicht haben will
was ist er hat mit verstehen zu tun also
man möchte es wieder verstehen und es
wieder ähm und dann darf es nicht
selbstverständlich sein und da sehe ich
die großen Aufgaben mit diesen zwei
Bereichen aber das ist mein Programm
sozusagen genau danke da würde ich dann
noch mal ähm zurückbiegen sozusagen wir
haben jetzt einige Dinge gehört zum
philosophischen Programm der
digitalisierungsforschung oder Reflexion
von Digitalität auch von digitalen
Methoden aber wie ist es denn mit der
Philosophie selbst also wir hatten das
vorhin schon gehört es gab es gibt ja
immer noch so ein paar
berührungsschwierigkeiten das kann auch
mit diesen mit dem blackboxing im
Anschluss an Freud kann man das ja auch
das unheimliche
nennen sind das sozusagen die mit die
berührungsschwierigkeiten die
Philosophie mit ihrer eigenen
Transformation digitalen Transformation
auch hier im Bereich oder als Digital
Humanities hat oder hat das andere
Gründe also ich glaube dass
jör da ganz gut also der hat ja mit
seinen seinen Ideen das philosophisch am
philosophisch nächste Programm mein ist
ja eher wissenschaftstechnik
forscherisch J willst du ein bisschen
was dazu sagen du warst vorher
Weg ja Kategorien Transformation der
Kategorien das klassisch philosophisches
Ansatz ja also ich habe eben versucht
mal Kategorien zu
prägen riff der
interobjektivität
hat schon Vorarbeit geleistet der
betrifft uns neuartige
gegenstandsbeziehung wenn wir uns auf
Maschinen beziehen h irgendwas zwischen
Subjektivität und objektiv sind also die
Kategorien von Subjektivität
Objektivität
gerade Bewegung
dann da ist irgendwie über so ist besser
glaube ich unsere mentalen Gehalte
können nach außen transportiert und
vermittelt werden durch die
Trägerstruktur des Internets
ähm das ist eine und dann gibt's
natürlich noch
ähm weitere Kategorien die
ähm auch unser
menschenaschinverhältnis betreffen ähm
eben die die Erweiterung unseres unserer
mentalen Gehalte durch die Vernetzung
Internet äh das Internet war ja auch ein
großes Gedächtnis ist ne also hier
geraden ganz viele bisher auch
epistemische Kategorien in Bewegung und
wichtig finde ich vor allem den Begriff
der interobjektivität
äh der zeigt dass wir einfach ein neues
Gegenstands und maschinenbezug
etablieren nicht mehr so wie zu einem
Hammer ein herkönmmlichen Werkzeug uner
Verhältnis zur KI ist von anderer Art
auch deswegen weil unsere eigenen Daten
in dieses Instrument ja mit ein
einbezogen werden durch diese
datencorporat das heißt wir treten
irgendwie in den neuen KI Methoden und
mit Medien wieder auf was im
hammert so nicht der
Fall ich finde eigentlich Jonathan die
eine wichtige Frage hast du ja auch
gestellt eben nämlich nach dem
Verhältnis zwischen Philosophie und
digital humananities das natürlich ein
gebrochenes Verhältnis ist dazu muss ich
nicht viel sagen aber wenn man sich klar
macht wie ich meine dass die digital
humananities mit ihren datengetriebenen
quantifizierenden Forschungsmethoden
überhaupt nur Sinn machen wenn es
besonders große datencorpora
egal welche Art zu analysieren gilt wenn
es stimmt dass also eine diese
empirizität ihres Gegenstandes die
Voraussetzung dafür ist dass man
überhaupt sinnvoll mit
computergenierten Forschungsdaten
intensiven Verfahren arbeitet dann ist
klar dass es in der Philosophie nicht
sehr viele Fragen gibt die in dieses
Format einer durch empirische Forschung
zu stützenden Arbeit gebracht werden
können es gibt schon einige ne man weiß
etwa dass John Stewart Mills seine
berühmten ethischen Schriften nicht
alleine abgefasst hat sondern dass seine
Frau und teilweise auch seine Tochter
mitgeschrieben haben und es geht diese
autorattribution kann man weil man
Briefe frauentchter hat heute sehr gut
mit Hilfe des Computers auswerrten wo es
Passagen in diesem Werk von John Stuart
Mills gibt die aber tatsächlich nicht
aus seiner Feder stammen also das wäre
z.B ein philosopisch eventuell
aufschlussreiches zusche aber man muss
ja zugeben dass empirische Fragen in der
Philosophie eine kleine und geringe
Rolle spielen und deshalb wird auch
immer die Frage nach den Digital
humananities prekär bleiben aber und das
ist mir eben ganz wichtig man muss ja
wenn man die Auswirkung der digital ität
auf Geisteswissenschaften und
Philosophie analysieren will
unterscheiden zwischen den engeren
digital humananities einerseits und der
Kulturtechnik digitaler Literalität der
sich eigentlich keiner der
geisteswissenschaftlichen Forschenden
überhaupt entziehen kann ne von der
E-Mail kommmunikation über die
Sucharbeit mit
Suchmaschinen was auch immer wissen wir
heute es gehört zur Gelehrten Praktik
mit digitalen Ressourcen und
Kommunikationswegen umzugehen und in
Bezug auf diese Kulturtechnik der
Digitalität dain da verändert sich
entscheidendes und ich habe das schon
mal erwähnt wir wissen noch überhaupt
nicht inwiefern
GPT die Prüfverfahren verändert weil wir
nicht mehr wirklich in der Lage sind zu
unterscheiden ob Studierende
mithilfe von gbt gearbeitet haben oder
nicht und
insofern könnte es sein dass das
mündliche z.B Prüfverfahren jetzt nur
als Hypothese eine Aufwertung empfehrt
oder was auch immer jedenfalls die Front
so will ich mal sagen an der
nachzudenken ist über die Rolle des
digitalen in der Philosophie ist gar
nicht so sehr die Frage sind die Digital
Humanities anwendbar und ist mehr die
Frage wie die Kulturtechnik digitaler
Literalität aussehen wird im Rahmen der
Geisteswissenschaften und dann auch der
Philosophie also ich wäre da nicht ganz
so pessimistisch weil es wird zw immer
gesagt Philosophie ist hermenutisch und
das steht so dem digitalen entgegen aber
die Philosophie hat nur ein Bruchteil
von hermeneutischen Fragen also äh die
Logik macht wahnsinnig viel Fortschritte
im Moment durch das digitale die
Wissenschaftsphilosophie kann das
digitale äußerst gut benutzen die ähm
also als Analyseinstrument aber eben
auch als erkenntnisinstrument die ähm es
gibt viele Bereiche wo man das die
werden immer so schnell vergessen äh
Begriff sanalyse lässt sich anders
denken über größere corpora als wir das
früher machen konnten wenn man das
ordentlich macht und auch die
entsprechenden Werkzeuge hat also vieles
kann man anders machen Gebrauchs
weiß nicht ob es da schon die
Algorithmen gibt wenn du sagst
Gebrauch von von Begriffen der lässt
sich jetzt ganz anders untersuchen wir
haben es wird nur im Moment noch zu
einseitig und eindimensional gedacht in
der Philosophie meines Erachtens ich
möchte mal dran erinnern dass z.B einer
der besten vir humanties arbeiten ist
otel ist die Politik wo er 100 über 100
Staatsformen vergleicht das würde man
heute alles digital machen und hätte ein
fantastisches Buch und daraus generierte
die Politik mit verschiedenen Konzepten
also das man muss n ein bisschen tiefer
Graben also das spielt schon eine Rolle
und für mich ist ja der Computer selbst
das philosophisch der aller
also die der Computer kommt für mich aus
der Philosophie nicht nur wegen leidnit
sondern weil einfach dieses Programm der
Oper Rationalisierung des Geistes ist
ein genuin philosophisch und am Anfang
stehen halt Leute wie decard und wie
lenit und vor allem die die englischen
die schottischen emperisten ja und ohne
die wäre das alles diese ganze
Entwicklung nicht denkbar und wenn dann
z.B new und Simon mit dem General
problem solver denselben move machen wie
das decart macht das kannst Du
tatsächlich an den Texten nachweisen
dann finde ich das ganz erstaunlich um
etliche Jahrhunderte später und so viel
weiter ist man da auch noch nicht man
kann nur viel mehr Daten verarbeiten das
ist der einzige Unterschied aber von den
von den Konzepten ist das noch teilweise
sehr klassisch und ich glaube dass da
viel dass man in der Philosophie viel
machen kann man muss nur ein bisschen
unvoreingenommener Drang gehen und nicht
und diese hermenoutik ist für mich ein
bisschen an manchen Stellen überschätzt
sage ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
Provan weil man man macht sie auch
empirisch in ein gewissen Weise also
niemand würde mehr so Systeme machen
idealistische Systeme die überhaupt
keinen Realitätsbezug mehr haben also
das GL ich die Zeiten sind irgendwie
auch vorbei nur so richtig
Handlungsmuster haben wir noch nicht wie
wir das gut machen können glaub ich die
fehlen noch ein bisschen na ja ich meine
mit der hermenutik gabrieleat ziehen wir
auch in einem Strang also ich finde ich
habe das unter dem Stachel des digitalen
Stichwort gefasst dass ich gerade das
Gute an diesen digital human
dass sie klar machen dass immer schon
das annotieren das Sammeln von Daten das
bibliografieren Abstracts machen
exerpieren all diese Dinge die heute
eben auch schon die Algorithmen und
Maschinen können dass das immer schon
ein Teil der Gelehrten Arbeit war und
das Interpretation und hermenutik
sozusagen als die Schlüssel Methode und
Königskrone geisteswissenschaftlicher
Methodik immer schon ein völlig
übersteigertes absolutistisches und wenn
man so will falsches Programm gewesen
ist dass die Materialität das Handwerk
des Geistes in den
Geisteswissenschaften ständig unter sich
begraben hat und für mich ist die
Debatte über die Digitalisierung über
die Möglichkeiten solche Werkzeuge z.B
zur Begriffsanalyse einzusetzen eben
auch die Chance zu erinnern dass die
Geisteswissenschaften immer schon ich
wiederhole das jetzt noch mal ein
Handwerk des Geistes entwickelt hab und
dass das die Bedingung der Möglichkeit
gewesen ist für
höherstufige kognitive Abläufe wie z.B
für das interpretiert ja
ja ja ich denke auch dass ähm wie hier
einen das ist das ist vielleicht mein
Beitrag den ich an der Stelle auch
beisteuern kann ähm dass wir einen
andauernden Diskurs brauchen
insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund sich
ständig ändern der Technologien also
letztes Jahr hat man ganz viel über das
Metaversum gesprochen jetzt spricht man
über GPT und es gibt im Prinzip
monatlich neue Entwicklungen da stellt
sich für mich auch die Frage ob es so
eine Art überspannende allgemeine
Theorie der Digitalität geben kann
die stabil ist sozusagen und Kontingenz
invariant was ist die Entwicklung
betrifft aber was ich denke ist dass es
auf jeden Fall ein ein Diskurs braucht
der diese Entwicklungen
begleitet das würde ich auch
unterstützen und noch ganz kurz und
nicht diese ethische Ethik reduzieren
weil das ist im Moment glaube ich wier
Ethik teilweise ins Spiel kommt nicht
wirklich produktiv und Philosophie wird
viel zu sehr auf Ethik heute
zurückgestuft und die kann aber viel
mehr und das finde ich sehr schade wei
wie du das siehst aber das sollte man
nicht immer nur auf diese
Fragestellung
ja da bin ich
vollkommen einer Meinung die
Überbewertung der Ethik die das ist auch
so eine Art von Kompensation man
versteht wenig und versucht dann
irgendwie so mit Verhaltensnormen
zu arbeiten aber Jonathan ich würde
gerne noch mal auf eine Frage von dir
oder etwas dass du aufgeworfen hast
Antworten also die Tatsache äh ja dass
dass wir äh wie soll ich jetzt sagen die
diese Operationalisierung des also gibt
es so eine übergreifende Theorie des
digitalen das war irgendwie deine Frage
und äh ich hätte vielleicht einen
Vorschlag dazu oder einen Beitrag also
für mich ist die ganze Geschichte der
technologischen Unterstützung unserer
Arbeiten und unserer Lebenswelten läuft
darauf hinaus dass wir immer mehr
Bereiche die für uns der menlichchen
Perspektive mit Interpretation Sinn und
Bedeutung zu tun tun haben in einer
Weise strukturieren dass sie von
Maschinen so ausgeführt werden können
dass sie nur noch mit operativer
Bedeutung arbeiten da jetzt würde das
voraussetzen den Unterschied zwischen
Sinn und operativer Bedeutung aber das
will ich jetzt hier nicht entwickeln
aber wir alle erkennen operativ dass das
Pluszeichen eben bedeutet eine Addition
von zwei Zahlen auszuführen das wäre das
Triviale Beispiel ein operativen
Bedeutung und im Grunde genommen würde
Digitalisierung darin bestehen dass wir
versuchen immer mehr Bereiche die bisher
gesättigt sind durch Sinn hermenutik und
das symbolische und die Bedeutung so
aufzubereiten das sage ich noch mal das
Maschinen diese Bereiche operativ auf
eine nicht hermenneutiche Weise
bearbeiten können und ich glaube da gibt
es überhaupt keine Grenzen keine festen
die wir setzen können auch gdel hab
jetzt in diesem Zusammenhang etwa nicht
zu suchen der ja immer ganz gerne dann
zitiert wird für die Grenzen des
formalen und das ist glaube ich unsere
Herausforderung und dieser Prozess wird
immer weitergehen der ist
unübersehbar aber jede äh sozusagen
jeder Ausgliederung einer
bedeutungsintensiven Operation äh an
eine Maschine geht wie ich meine ein
herer damit dass ich neue tätigkeits
kreative Tätigkeitsprofile auf Seite
Menschen entwickeln nicht in ein und
derselben Person das ist das soziale
Drama dass die Automatisierung natürlich
partiell freisetetzt und ersetzt
menschliche Arbeitskraft aber an anderer
Stelle wird Arbeitskraft in einer ganz
neuen Weise wiederum gebraucht ja das
wollte ich sagen und das ist für mich
das Wesen der Digitalisierung die
Operationalisierung von Sinn und
Interpretation das war do ein schönes
Schlusswort ich muss leider raus weil
ich habe Meeting tut mir leid das war so
knapp heute alles genau wir kommen auch
sowieso zum Ende vielen vielen Dank an
euch alle für die Zeit für das Gespräch
und genau wir sehen uns macht's gut war
super hat Spaß gemacht Ciao danke an
euch tschüss